[Musique]
et je me trouve justement avec Aurélie
sulfizio pour confectionner mon propre
pain d'épices alors Aurélie on commence
par quoi alors nous on a fait les
maisons au préalable avant votre arrivée
donc une pâte à pain d'épices ou dans un
batteur on va mélanger la farine la
levure les œufs et un mélange d'épices
avec de la cannelle de la misère de la
badiane et d'autres que je ne citerai
pas pour des raisons et là on va
s'attaquer aux décorations des petites
maisons super bah je vais essayer de pas
faire n'importe quoi vous allez c'est
facile vous avez déjà tenu une poche à
douille
[Musique]
on a fait des couleurs c'est de la glace
royale ça s'appelle c'est un mélange de
blanc d'oeuf de sucre glace avec un
zeste de citron auquel on ajoute du
colorant naturel
[Musique]
vous avez mis deux secondes pour faire
les deux
façades
pour faire ma première fois c'est normal
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
ça fait un peu pain d'épice donc pain
d'épices d'enfants quand même je pense
que la première fois que j'en ai fait je
devais être pire que vous
maintenant qu'on a fini on va passer au
montage de la maison on va faire un
cornet de chocolat blanc qu'on a et
c'est ce qui va nous servir de colle
justement
[Musique]
bon ben elles sont pas mal nos maisons
quand même
merci beaucoup Aurélie plusieurs pour
tous vos conseils
peuvent faire leur propre pain d'épices
et décorer leur propre coin des pistes